dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly on IIFA here today we
are going to listen to some amazing
improvements in the area of AI based
voice cloning for instance if someone
wanted to clone my voice there are hours
and hours of my recordings on YouTube
and elsewhere
they could do it with previously
existing techniques but the question
today is if we had even more advanced
methods to do this how big of a sound
sample would we really need for this do
we need a few hours a few minutes the
answer is no not at all
hold on to your papers because this new
technique only requires five seconds
let's listen to a couple examples the
Norseman considered the rainbow as a
bridge over which the gods passed from
Earth to their home in the sky take a
look at these pages for Crooked Creek
Drive
there are several listings for gas
station
here's the forecast for the next four
days
these take the shape of a long round
arch with its path high above and it's
two ends apparently beyond the horizon
take a look at these pages for Crooked
Creek Drive
there are several listings for gas
station
here's the forecast for the next full
days
absolutely incredible the timbre of the
voice is very similar and it is able to
synthesize sounds and consonants that
have to be inferred because they were
not heard in the original voice sample
this requires a certain kind of
intelligence and quite a bit of that so
while we are at that how does this new
system work well it requires three
components one the speaker encoder is a
neural network that was trained on
thousands and thousands of speakers and
is meant to squeeze all this learned
data into a compressed representation in
other words it tries to learn the
essence of human speech from many many
speakers to clarify I will add that this
system listens to thousands of people
talking to learn the intricacies of
human speech but this training step
needs to be done only once and after
that it was allowed just five seconds of
speech data from someone they haven't
heard of previously and later
the synthesis takes place using these
five seconds as an input - we have a
synthesizer that takes text as an input
this is what we would like our test
subject to say and it gives us a math
spectrogram which is a concise
representation of someone's voice and
the intonation the implementation of
this module is based on deep my stack
Ultron - technique and here you can see
an example of this math spectrogram
built for a male and two female speakers
on the Left we have the spectrograms for
the reference recordings the voice
samples if you will and on the right we
specify a piece of text that we would
like the learning algorithm to utter and
it produces this corresponding
synthesized spectrograms but eventually
we would like to listen to something and
for that we need a waveform as an output
so the third element is thus a neuro
vocoder that does exactly that and this
component is implemented by deep minds
wavenet technique this is the
architecture that led to these amazing
examples so how do you measure exactly
how amazing it is when we have a
solution evaluating it is also anything
but trivial in principle we are looking
for a result that is both
close to the recording that we have of
the target person but says something
completely different and all this in a
natural manner this naturalness and
similarity can be measured but we are
not nearly done yet because the problem
gets even more difficult for instance it
matters how we fit the three puzzle
pieces together and then what data we
train it on of course also matters a
great deal here you see that if we train
on a one data set and test the results
against a different one and then swap
the two and the results in naturalness
and similarity will differ significantly
the paper contains a very detailed
evaluation section that explains how to
deal with these difficulties the mean
opinion score is measured in this
section which is a number that describes
how well a sound sample would pass as
genuine human speech and we haven't even
talked about the speaker verification
part so make sure to have a look at the
paper so indeed we can clone each
other's voice by using a sample of only
five seconds what a time to be alive
this episode has been supported by
weights and biases weights and biases
provides tools to track your experiments
in your deep learning projects it can
save you a ton of time and money in
these projects and is being used by
opening a Toyota Research Stanford and
Berkeley they also wrote a guide on the
fundamentals of neural networks where
they explain in simple terms how to
train a neural network properly what are
the most common errors you can make and
how to fix them it is really great you
get to have a look so make sure to visit
them through Wendy b.com slash papers
WEA and DB comm slash papers or just
click the link in the video description
and you can get a free demo today
our thanks to weights and biases for
helping us make better videos for you
thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time